we have this story from star tribune and
this is despicable albert lee restaurant
owner found guilty of violating state
coveted mandate a jury of three women
and three men took only an hour of
deliberation to convict lisa hansen
she was sentenced to where we have the
sentencing down here it's uh there we go
she was sentenced to 90 days in jail
which began immediately and a 1 000 fine
considerably considerably more than what
albert lee city attorney kelly don
martinez who prosecuted the case had
sought meaning the prosecutor didn't
even want to go that crazy and the judge
was like nah lock her up three months
why because she opened her wine and beer
bar
flouting tim waltz's executive order to
shut down last winter during the coven
19 pandemic and was found guilty of six
criminal misdemeanor counts thursday by
a free-born county jury
it was it was cops who came and arrested
her for this this is minnesota this is
minnesota she fled to iowa and then
sheriff deputies came and arrested her
so these are people these are officers
look you got to understand in places
like new york city as much as you might
be saying like well the nypd weren't the
ones going out and doing this the the
leadership are appointed by democrats
they do not believe in the same moral
systems moral frameworks and values that
we here do just because we might be like
there are good cops out there and
they'll be smurching the name of
officers over you know a few fringe
cases you need to realize that in places
like seattle there are antifa cops right
there
yeah i mean there was an antifa person
running for the uh basically like
attorney general of the city
um in seattle and then you know she lost
but uh she was
entrenched you know she was running for
that it's interesting too i was talking
to some friends about this the other day
there's a
there's definitely a difference today
between um the way that republicans and
democrats conservatives liberals
whatever terminology you want to use
approach things it used to be that
everyone basically seemed to have the
same goal
and the question was how do we get there
what is the process
um i don't think there's
the same goal in mind at all and i don't
think that
there's even a similarity of world view
at this point yeah i i think for the
most part everyone's become increasingly
selfish
and like the judge in this case or the
prosecutors they're just basically like
i'm gonna get mine yeah i don't care i
mean we're seeing what's happening all
around the world and it should be a
warning shot to the rest of the world
especially with what's happening in
germany in australia in austria and
italy in france where we're seeing just
you know elderly women walking by big
police officers grabbing their hands
demanding to see their papers demanding
to see their identification and throwing
them in jail giving them huge fines
stealing their hard-earned money
punishing them scaring the crap out of
them because they didn't comply with the
whims of the state i think what's
happening around the world in some of
these places is what a lot of
politicians want to happen here in the
united states and i think because of
people fighting against it because of
people not complying because of the
state of florida and other people saying
hey i believe in my human rights i have
dignity i have a life here that i will
fight for and i will protect no matter
what i think that's one of the only
reasons why uh society totally hasn't
gone the way as many other societies
have gone to where even protesting even
just simply complaining
is banned or made illegal and and it's
absolutely crazy to see that happen in
australia to see that happen all over
europe where you can't even protest
that's crazy we have that here with
corporations corporations ban protest
in the us how so well you have twitter
you have social media platforms well
they've been using speech they ban
speech and speeches protest yeah and
they also and they also ban people from
organizing and from having groups and
doing events together covering the
elaine maxwell trial yeah that's another
big one
it's obvious what they're doing they're
like it's bad enough we had to pull this
stupid campaign with maxwell anyway the
last thing we wanted someone to be
tweeting about it right yeah or just no
talking talking about the justice system
oh you know or just you're saying it's
terrible or just how the government took
your tax dollars for over 30 years and
ran an international extortion child
trafficking operation that's another big
one you know okay yeah
that's that's something that
look i think you know we've seen a lot
of the details out of the epstein stuff
and now we're kind of getting off the
rails from where we just were it's like
you know these small town cops arresting
this woman and then epstein and an
internet no but i will say there's a
simpler there's a simpler thing it's
like
you've got
how much how much of our money without
our consent goes to literally bombing
civilians right and and and for some
nebulous cause where they tell us what
are they saying they were saying on tv
about ukraine we we fight over there so
we don't got to fight here and i'm like
you think russia is going to invade
the continental u.s
let alone hawaii and then just a really
quick point before i'm going to leave it
off to you i think it is interconnected
because there was police officers in new
york city in florida that knew exactly
what was going on they had the victims
they had children that were coming to
them and they were told to shut up by
their superiors and they had to shut up
and there was no justice for thousands
of victims and thousands of children
that came forward so sorry go ahead
wow yeah yeah you didn't know about this
no i don't know all about it okay okay
oh the epstein stuff is yeah the
absolute stuff is out yeah i mean i've
read about the upstairs yeah there's a
number of police officers that fell into
depression there's a number of police
officers that were silenced shunned and
couldn't do their job because the higher
up said shut up obey our orders and they
did and they had to
that's what goes on with a lot of things
yeah you know that's pretty clear yeah
and it happens in some of the most
atrocious atrocities that we can't even
mention or talk about and and that to me
is frustrating to understand people
still putting a lot of their faith in a
lot of their power and a lot of their
hope which i think is is needless into
this kind of system that they're going
to be doing the right thing i think we
should be more skeptical than just
hopeful from my perspective you know
when i think about cops defunding police
and police as an organization i think
like the trash people pick up the trash
and you're like okay if there's an
organization of trashment across the
united states and a small group of them
started dumping trash on lawns and they
were like f this we hate these and
they're like targeting black people you
know some racist trash men you wouldn't
say like defund trash people no no more
trash pickups you totally need the
garbage club
the same so like right how do you deal
with or i mean just firefighters and
police
imagine a video of a firefighter at a
fire and he like he's got the hose and a
little old lady walks by he just sprays
her and she gets knocked over and
they're like time to shut down the fire
department
it's over fire
how do you hold them accountable you
criticize every time they do something
wrong you try to hold them accountable
and if they don't if they're not held
accountable they shouldn't have any
institutional power or money until they
can be accountable
until they can be trustworthy until they
can be honest and real with the people
that they're serving because they're
supposed to be serving the people not
doing the bidding of the special
interests that many times they just take
the orders blindly and do whatever they
want there was a there was a big thing
during occupy wall street where nypd
were working uh in uniform as private
security for wealthy individuals who
want to go to restaurants in the
financial district right that makes
sense
so so you come out as a protester and
you see police officers in uniform
badges and everything and then you
realize they were hired as private
security
for the wealthy elites of new york city
there's a lot of cops that moonlight as
security but in uniform with their
badges i don't think they're supposed to
do that well there's an official program
within the nypd where corporations could
hire police officers to show up at their
businesses many banks use police
officers and hire them i don't know if
this program still exists but i know it
did exist a few years ago yeah and they
were able to hire pay pay their salaries
and they would show up particularly
protect uh their business and
essentially just stand around there
because that was a deterrent for a lot
of criminals seeing oh there's a police
officer here i won't come and steal from
this place oops sorry though trashing
the joints dude their job is to protect
people but then
but their real job is to do what their
supervisor tells them to do or they're
going to lose the job yeah so like
that's a big conflict of interest right
off the bat including up to some of the
worst atrocities i mean isn't that true
of soldiers isn't that true of the
military any of these kind of
enforcement organizations are all about
making sure that the people are
following the orders like you can't have
a bunch of people it just wouldn't work
if everyone was out there
making their own assumptions about how
the law works you know there has to be a
coordinate effort coordinated effort in
order for it to be successful and right
now it's running through people like um
authoritarian individuals so maybe in
the future we'll the system will be
altered so that
we'll be able to police without having
authority
telling people what to do i don't think
that that's really how it works
i think there always has to be authority
to tell people
if you're going to have a if you're
going to have some sort of army
people have to follow the orders in the
army
i'm not policing though policing i mean
in new york city like that's that's an
army
to a certain extent yeah how many is
like 30 something thousand it's a lot
it's a lot of people and the thing too
that happened in new york is that a
bunch of um low-level crimes basically
got decriminalized and stopped being
prosecuted
so that just opened the door for
criminals to do bigger crimes you know
and the way that these smaller crimes
worked i was actually listening to a
podcast about this with inez and that is
nice yeah and has this podcast um
but essentially the idea is that those
low-level crimes
are not that
are now decriminalized the idea was not
that those low-level crimes are there to
be prosecuted and send people to prison
it's so that police have an intervention
point an early intervention point right
so if you're standing there on the
street corner smoking a joint
uh then the police can be like hey
what's up you're standing here on the
street corner smoking a joint that's an
intervention point right uh if turn
style jumping right hey you just jump
the turnstiles that's an intervention
point what other you know what else is
going on right and when you have a bunch
of crimes right and then people plead
down once they're in the court system so
then you have like this person went up
for a drug offense for you know five
years
did they really go up just for the drug
offense like they pled down a whole
bunch of other charges and landed with
one and took a sentence
it's sort of interesting i hadn't
thought of it in those terms
um but it makes sense when you start
thinking about it in that in that way
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you